salut brut je m'appelle kabila j'y serai aujourd'hui
l'interview
[Musique]
Je suis né au Sénégal et j'ai grandi
envoyé les documents au logement social
TIC Tac
mes vidéos sur youtube avec mes amis
J'ai fait beaucoup de vidéos avec la mienne
amis même s'il ne ressemblait plus à personne
proche mais j'ai aimé les faire alors c'est le cas
La quarantaine est arrivée et j'ai découvert
tout
oui oui, j'ai fait de nombreux travaux
maçon travaillait comme lave-vaisselle, je faisais le
serveur, j'ai fait un contrôle mécanique
numérique, le nettoyeur de vitres a travaillé un peu dessus
un peu fatigant on fait deux boulots avant
de la quarantaine, j'avais deux emplois chez
il y a un jour
où j'étais maçon et je travaillais le soir
le chevalier lave-vaisselle l'a fait pour
deux ans
c'est facile, il n'était pas sûr
donner à estimer que les travaux
mettre en quarantaine diverses choses mais toutes les miennes
la vie a été des moments difficiles
difficiles ont été trois ont été
beaucoup si je devais dire exactement le
ma vie
même 10 entretiens ne suffiraient pas
Je dis juste que je te souhaite le meilleur
tout et de
ne t'arrête pas au premier obstacle
parce que malheureusement la vie
la vie la vie n'est pas des roses et des fleurs
mais honnêtement non
je voulais je voulais devenir je voulais
je suis devenu acteur depuis que j'ai vu
le prince de bel air
smith et là je me suis dit c'est exactement ça
Je voulais me lancer dans ce voyage ici
Mais j'espère y arriver un jour
Quoi qu'il en soit, je n'aurais jamais imaginé
tout ça
oui oui oui oui oui j'aime beaucoup les massifs
nous avons aussi de vos nouvelles de temps en temps
Nous n'avons pas encore eu WhatsApp
de manière
retrouve-nous quand il est libre
J'ai un engagement et un engagement libre
Je n'avais jamais trouvé un moyen de nous attraper
[Musique]
quand il est fait de banane
J'ai vu mes abonnés
monte comme jamais auparavant
Honnêtement, je n'ai jamais regardé le
chiffres que je n'ai jamais regardés à un follower
parce que honnêtement, je m'en fiche
oui je suis content de mon follower et de tout
mais ce n'est pas encore si tu les regardes
classement premier selon le monde
Ça ne m'intéresse pas, je ferais des vidéos
même si j'étais
aucun comme je l'ai toujours fait avec YouTube
non, je ne l'ai toujours pas fait, en fait, je ne le fais pas
la vidéo parce que j'aime les faire
par hasard, c'est arrivé assez sans
succès
Honnêtement, je n'ai pas peur de
celui qui s'arrête parce que justement moi
je ne regarde pas les classements je ne regarde pas les
des chiffres, je continue à faire ce que je fais
par passion s'il le fallait un jour
arrête, je continue à faire ce que c'est
ce que j'aime faire rire les gens
les gens et je continuerai à le faire
j'espère je l'espère en tout cas oui je suis très
fier de moi et j'ai réussi
pour lui trouver une maison alors
J'ai peu d'amis et ceux que j'ai sont
ceux-là sont dignes de confiance, de toute façon, je peux
toujours connaître des gens ou un bon
œil
J'ai fait beaucoup de choses avec
Weston se bat avec un Kimi, pas un avec
Neymar avec toi fais bien que je suis très
content d'avoir rencontré des gens comme ça
qui es-tu, tu les vois à la télé, mais quand ils
tu sais, apprends, connais-les, ils sont vraiment
toutes les bonnes personnes
je suis, je suis un joueur de la Juventus mais j'ai
beaucoup d'amis de Paris
Mais je les soutiens parce que j'ai des amis qui
ils jouent et je les soutiens en équipe
ce que je dis toujours à tout le monde, ce n'est pas le cas
ne soyez pas limité par les limites de
les autres gens
Rien
au revoir